yeah that wasn't out there with him they
would have really been investigated up
there for those of you who just got home
from the neighborhood movie house and
tuned in for the news this is it the
47th Annual Academy Awards
now the next gentlemen we own it is a
motion picture executive chairman of the
board of United Artists corporation he's
also a lawyer director of Transamerica
corporation consultant to two presidents
of the United States and fields of
science health education human rights
and public affairs also trustee of
Columbia University governor of the
Veidt sment Institute of science leader
for many years in our country's
relationships with developing nations of
Africa active in the Urban League the
Catholic Charities of New York and the
Will Rogers Hospital and all this and
much more and the Board of Governors of
the Academy present him with the Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award no man in
our industry has sought it less or
deserves it more than Arthur Krim
thank you Frank for those generous words
motion picture people are so well known
for their dedication to humanitarian
causes that I feel that I am merely
standing in on this one occasion for
what so many of my colleagues do day in
and day out most important of all I
would like to say how proud I am to
receive an award from an industry which
in the last 60 years has become our
number one asset in reaching out to the
hearts and the minds of countless
millions of people throughout the world
and which literally every day reminds
them of the freedom and the diversity
and the greatness of our country and so
for all this and much more my deep
appreciation to the governors and to the
members of the Academy for giving me
this Oscar which I will always treasure
thank you very much